in the early history of the LDS Church
the plant documents are mentioned so
I've taken those documents kind of as my
foundational start and expanded they
were hoping to create a society that was
good I just was amazed how detail it was
this is David Hall a Mormon engineer
who's setting out to do the impossible
to create a new high-tech high density
city of Zion what we're trying to do is
get a lot of people together in a small
space and have that acreage also involve
agriculture industry and community
things all together he's still in the
modeling phase but he has a hundred and
fifty staff working on everything from
elevator design to supercharged Wi-Fi to
something called toilet analytics we're
doing new medical digital devices with
the toilet
basically this prototyping will help him
build a community for twenty thousand
people that sustainable but also
scalable so that is not just one cell of
twenty thousand people but at least 50
of those cells until you have a million
people he's also completely self-funding
this he and his father made a lot of
money through synthetic diamond drilling
I'm putting it all in I'm gonna die
broke herself to make his project real
he needs land
and for that he had one special place in
mind
the reason why I'm purchasing in Vermont
is Joseph Smith was one of the ones that
came up with the documents and it's
where he was born
right there in Vermont and so it's it's
a way to honor his legacy it he never
got it done himself right but maybe
others can get it figured out and get it
working properly I had known this piece
next to us it's old and I immediately
knew it had to been this guy that bought
it I didn't know anybody would care but
eventually people found out about it and
did care and so right away I'm thinking
boy what's going to be going on on the
hill and why you're buying all this land
so I told well maybe someday I'll do a
community scared crap I mean to be
honest with you it's very scary
it's just something entirely foreign to
small towns Vermont
yeah and it's literally over those hills
that will be the end of quiet
guy shows up with his money and takes
over to give a little context the
population around the Joseph Smith
Memorial is just under 7,000 people
so David Hall's proposal to bring three
times as many people to form a closed
community doesn't exactly sit well with
the locals to me it doesn't matter why
he wants to come here in particular but
but coming here is just it's the wrong
place
maybe there's no place for his
development maybe there's lots of places
I don't know but this one certainly is
the wrong
the couches at all and the idea that
it's sustainable and it's green and it's
future looking but he's not asked
anybody here there's people here who
have been farming for seven generations
and he's not asked any of them how can I
help you with my millions of dollars how
how could I help you be more sustainable
so far David Hall is acquired about a
third of the land he needs for his first
community but he still expects it could
be decades perhaps even past his own
lifetime before his vision is realized
my biggest fear is that I'll have a
enough opposition and enough people that
are totally against it that I give up
but I'm pretty persistent so I don't
think it'll happen